[Música]
en france 24 es momento de hablar de
ciencia y tecnología soy valentina
torres sánchez y es un gusto
acompañarlos damos inicio en ucrania
naciones unidos alertó que la ofensiva
rusa ha provocado la crisis de
refugiados más rápida en europa desde la
segunda guerra mundial pues dos
estudiantes de la universidad de harvard
crearon green take shelter puntocom un
portal web independiente para ayudar a
los ucranianos a encontrar refugio en
todo el mundo
puntualmente el fin de la página es
emparejar anfitriones potenciales con
aquellos que necesitan un lugar donde
quedarse
nuestros objetivos al crear este sitio
web eran hacerlo lo más intuitivo y
seguro posible en primer lugar en la
facilidad de uso nos aseguramos de que
los refugiados puedan escribir
inmediatamente una ubicación y comenzar
a ver los resultados porque si están
huyendo del peligro te encuentras en una
situación de emergencia queremos que sea
lo más eficiente posible para nuestros
anfitriones ofrecemos muchas
oportunidades para que agreguen detalles
a sus perfiles etiquetas como qué
idiomas hablan para ayudarlos a
encontrar la mejor combinación
el portal ya cuenta con más de 18 mil
anfitriones voluntarios no obstante una
iniciativa de este tipo requiere de
numerosos controles de seguridad para
garantizar el bienestar de los
refugiados es por ello que el sitio guía
a los ciudadanos ucranianos a pedirle a
los anfitriones potenciales que
proporcionen sus nombres completos
perfiles de redes sociales información
sobre cualquier restricción para niños y
también solicitar videollamadas o fotos
donde se hospedarán quienes se
hospedarán con ellos y el área
circundante
asimismo advierte a los refugiados para
que estén atentos a señales de alerta
incluidas peticiones de citas previas
solicitudes sexuales a cambio de
alojamiento si la persona que los
contacto no es la misma del lugar al que
llegan o incluso si les pidan datos
financieros de espera sabemos que esta
es una situación potencialmente
peligrosa por lo que hemos implementado
muchos pasos para garantizar la
protección de nuestros refugiados
tenemos una guía detallada que
entregamos a todos los refugiados para
ayudarlos a verificar el anfitrión con
el que están hablando asegurarse de que
la persona con la que pueden estar
hablando por teléfono sea la misma con
la que se están reuniendo en persona
también tenemos un sistema de informes
detallados donde podemos eliminar
mensajes inapropiados listados estamos
trabajando con la organizaciones de
ayuda para obtener listados verificados
en la plataforma y tenemos mecanismos
para evitar que cualquier malhechor
intente hacer un mal uso del sitio web
vamos ahora hasta la capital de georgia
cada año millones de personas mueren en
el mundo por infecciones con bacterias y
esta condición cada vez se vuelve más
compleja debido a la resistencia que han
creado algunas bacterias a los
antibióticos pues los investigadores del
instituto él ya va de bacteriófagos
desarrollan lo que se conoce como virus
amigables que son capaces de comerse
esas bacterias y así salvarle la vida a
los pacientes
los bacteriófagos ocurren naturalmente
no hacen daño a nuestra flora normal y
lo más importante pueden matar o causar
ruptura de la membrana celular de
bacterias resistentes a los antibióticos
nuestro equipo produce 6 tipos
diferentes de bacteriófagos de amplio
espectro que pueden curar múltiples
enfermedades infecciosas los expertos
explican que los bacteriófagos un virus
que únicamente afectan las bacterias de
hecho explican que no todas las
bacterias pueden ser eliminadas por
pagos estándar como también son llamados
por ello explican que hay bacterias que
responden a un solo tipo de fax asimismo
el laboratorio trabaja para entrenar a
estos virus y hacerlos más precisos la
terapia de pagos es una de las
alternativas más importantes de los
antibióticos sin embargo no decimos que
puede reemplazar por completo a la
terapia con antibióticos pero se puede
convertir en un método crucial cuando el
patógeno ha desarrollado resistencia a
los antibióticos
nuestro trabajo es entrenar pagos por
manipulación en el laboratorio ellos
pueden matar un rango más amplio de
bacterias dañinas
finalizamos en reino unido donde
mediante inteligencia artificial un
robot pudo actuar profesionalmente junto
con la orquesta de jazz mar molinero de
la universidad de southampton el
software está equipado con un algoritmo
que le permitió crear e interpretar
solos improvisados
espn
el software ha sido alimentado con jazz
desde la década de 1920 hasta la
actualidad muchos solistas de jazz
diferentes el robot de escucha lo
almacena todo y lo coloca en una base de
datos luego selecciona las mejores
partes y aprende de él
space and dance for me así usar los
acordes la armonía que utilizamos en el
jazz y por último crea su propia versión
de solos
nutrida por todo este conocimiento que
tiene a lo largo de los años de la
música jazz y jazz mire que se trata de
un proyecto que examina cómo los humanos
y las máquinas pueden trabajar juntos en
el campo de la improvisación musical el
software ha sido llamado jazz
transformer o hits y crea piezas aparte
de datos de más de 500 solos de
estrellas del jazz así llegamos al final
de este espacio a ustedes gracias por su
sintonía continúen con nosotros en
france 24 y france 24 puntocom
[Música]
mañana